[Music]
these are German bombers in a movie
about some British kids escaping the war
into a mythical realm do we really need
sky captain in the world of yesterday
footage of these bombers maybe this is
why the movie is 2 hours 23 minutes long
this intense opening is meant to give us
context but it also builds a connection
to their home and their mother that the
movie will never revisit or resolve for
its entire two and a half hours you know
what else could get you killed beter
leaving that bunker door open just so
you can chastise your little brother
shut the door when boarding a train
please make sure to inform us if you are
starring in a film so you can be seated
my window on the station side for
maximum waving effect thank you and
enjoy your evacuation you won't listen
to your brother waiting Edmund you go
okay I will but um do you mean
emotionally like Dakota Fanning and man
on fire or do you mean physically like
ATS Monica on fronts or do you mean
spiritually like that will writer chick
movie isn't the Screwtape Letters mrs.
MacCready I'm afraid so
let me spend so much time Oliver
twisting an an of Green Gables I'm
beginning to wonder if it's ever going
to go narnia chronicling and above all
there should be no disturbing off the
professor oh now I understand this too
long setup they're hoping to create and
Norn your hurts which I guess they kind
of do for another movie or two why don't
I forget how it all worked out was it
Latin worst game ever invented Edmund is
such a miserable whiny little bastard
always correcting everyone and pointing
out the mistakes and hey random and
convenient completely empty chest is
both random and convenient she ran
through at least two hallways and is at
the far end of this room with the door
closed
I doubt she's hearing Peter at all Lucy
accidentally south into Narnia is
wandering into a fantasy world a common
occurrence for Lucy she doesn't seem
shocked or scared at all that this
closet led to some sort of winter
wonderland how is she at least not
running back the way she came at this
point to inspect what happened and
without proper orienteering skills and
basic intelligence Lucy died of
hypothermia long before the game of
hide-and-seek was over Lucy's left hand
touches the pole but an immediate cut
away shows it's her right hand and then
immediately her left again I haven't
seen pole work that fast since well
never mind
yes Losey be very afraid I've seen what
james mcavoy does when he's in beast
mode and you don't want any part of it
did this movie even have a continuity
Department the fingerprints are
different in almost every shot the
packages are in different places than
they land and if we track every
continuity error through this whole
thing we'll be here longer than a
Narnian winter let's just add 15 sins
and call it a day and from our fallen
fashion line we call this the topless
scarf look for when you have to keep
your neck warm and your nipples hard at
the same time and also most annoying
from from the lamppost all the way to
Castle CAIR Paravel on the eastern ocean
every stick and stone you see is not a
fun swimming why would she think she's
still in the wardrobe confusion about
where she is exactly sure but she does
know the difference between indoors and
outdoors right I would be if you came
and had tea with me well it would be
sort of like a kidnapping and an Amber
Alert would be issue lucy accepts the
half naked strangers invite to tee
further ignoring her siblings and how
many rules of hide-and-seek she's
breaking this entire movies events could
be avoided if Lucy would just act her
age and get scared of the snowscape and
goat stranger and run back through the
Wardrobe into the mansion in the dead of
winter are they frozen bucketloads I
read these books as a kid and loved them
I saw this movie isn't adult and thought
it was fine I'm watching this movie now
as a sinner God Almighty it's downright
insufferable other than the frostbite
you mean yeah I'm awesome
Matt Lauer
[Music]
what stuff it's like hey come to my
house for tea then psychedelic fluting
why would whatever magic powers this
thing has not let the siblings get to
narnia now if it's just gonna let them
do it the next time God even the
Wardrobe itself is involved in the
scheme to pad the runtime if she knows
she's going back to Narnia wouldn't she
do more to prepare then just slide some
boots on maybe a jacket huh some fun
repellent so Lucy comes through to
Narnia and immediately meets good guy
Tumnus Bombadil Edmund comes through
Narnia in the same spot mind you and
immediately meets bad guy Ice Queen its
Narnia super fucking tiny or just super
fucking convenient anything you'd like
to eat
Turkish Delight sheesh first Tumnus
traps Lucy in and fire flute roofie sir
now a discount collateral here is
basically running a hey kid want some
candy on Edmund I'm not sure who the
Nanyan version of Chris Hansen is but
they suck at their job grumpy dwarf as a
dick to magic chalices must assume she's
telling the truth
old goofy and confusing guy who likes to
smoke a pipe gives the small hero's
advice while seemingly just babbling
about gibberish again I'm not sure who
got there first but it's clear as day
Lewis and Tolkien we're writing their
famous fantasies at the exact same time
[Music]
cricket when did Lucy even have time to
make that snowball her hands are empty
here and peter has been looking at her
the whole time snowball fight really
it's your first time in a magical land
fully contained inside a wardrobe not
your first time seeing snow you dolt 30
seconds of filmmaking tricks designed to
make viewers scared and nervous only to
introduce a goddamn beaver it was a good
guy that will go in to help them this is
the movies version of a time-wasting
jump scare I can assume any
english-speaking upright-walking beaver
behaves completely like an actual beaver
for no apparent reason especially
considering beavers likely never met an
actual beaver to know how to beaver in
the first beaver beaver anything Susan
would be excellent at anthropomorphisms
open flame for a structure made entirely
of wood I'm just saying don't borrow a
faulty crock pot from the neighbors
that's all hmm large dam element of
danger
talking beavers sardines this movie has
most of my sexual fantasies all rolled
into one scene y would be ver think that
they knew this and we're joking he knows
they're not from here right they don't
even know about the prophecy prophecies
you know that
righty-right poem Nancy it's time the
four of us we're getting home at but
damn room is in no damn way big enough
for Edmund to have made his damn escape
without being seen these doors seemed a
bit impractical Edmund is a punk-ass
little bitch already ditched his family
and raced to the obviously Evil Queen
because she has some candy walks through
a field of statues that to me the casual
observer are clearly Medusa style frozen
real creatures and draws glasses in a
mustache on one Edmund spoopy should
have been called Chronicles of Narnia
Edmund is a pants also movie has time
for this
my apologies fortunate favourite of the
Queen or else not so fortunate jeez well
if you're gonna sinisterly for shout of
the Queen's evil intentions at least
wait until you're out of Edmonds earshot
to do so honestly I wrote narae's
several jokes about this line but
ultimately I can't shake the thought
that this way for your num-nums would
make an excellent band there man how
many movies is Liam Neeson in we're a
pack of wolves are the bad guys
movie Chiefs like my college girlfriend
here and it makes me furious because the
kids in Beaver are already gone when the
wolves show up but to keep the audience
surprised they edited the footage to
make it look like the Wolves had shown
up before they got away basically they
edited this with the editorial hand of a
keeping up with the kardashians show run
it's a good thing the Biebs built this
escape tunnel big enough for humans to
run through that's some pretty
impressive foresight I tell ya this
peril is a too small to cover the
opening be too light to not easily be
moved and see rollable this in no way
better is their predicament ah the old
hide high up in a tree and hope you can
remain quiet routine never mind how the
fuck they got up there so fast he ran
north smell them out if you can smell
them out why do you need his help with
the direction why can't you smell them
since they're really close near Rock the
time is short and esslyn himself has
asked me to gather more troops Fox News
I see they shot the scene on
green-screen mountain that Aslan's camp
is near the stone table just across the
frozen river awesome how the fuck do you
know that your own wife was shocked a
few minutes ago to meet a fox that had
met Aslan yeah you know the exact route
and location of the secret camp is this
coincidence or just a Bieber marriage so
torn apart by lies and distrust that
divorce is imminent long journey such
arduous Ness sole finish ship here's a
jump scare chase scene that has all the
tension of a genuinely scary moment
except that it ends with Santa Claus yep
santa claus as a movie ever jumped the
shark at its own halfway point i put up
with a lot since I got here
thing I said while watching the film
somehow went back in time and became
aligned in the script
Santa gives each human child a special
gift I'll allow the Wizard of Oz and I'm
suddenly starting to wonder if CS Lewis
was just really good at paying close
attention to other works of fiction that
captured the public's imagination also
it would've been hilarious if he gave
three of them cool swords and helmets
but then gave the last one a lame gift
like oh man socks trust in this boo and
it will not easily miss did the prophecy
about the humans on the throne say
anything about all the mythical and
magical help they would receive on their
way there what is happening right now a
frozen river while Lucy and the gang
pass flowering trees in the dead of
snowy winter leading me to believe they
inadvertently entered the shimmer have
you absorbed nothing about the prophecy
of Adam's descendants you're supposed to
be smart
look this is a massively super huge army
gathered here whereas that apparently is
and get the ice queen knew nothing of
Aslan's return or his location until
edmund told her gosh she has the worst
informants this unexplained scent or
makes a lot more sense than the one in
bright welcome Peter son of Adam even in
2005 Liam Neeson as Aslan was a bit of
casting that was too on the nose
the evil Gimli torments Edmund for fun
my question is why did they keep him
alive
and even if keeping him live has a good
excuse why did they bring him along into
battle please don't try to run now we're
tired and we prefer to kill you quickly
do you know because it seems to me
discount can work and the pack had the
upper hand until you blew in all with a
cheap jump scare ground instead of a
surprise attack
there was no way Susan covered that
amount of ground that quickly and got a
blow on that horn before being turned
into a wolf chow is it just me or does
Peter have a bad case of the wobbly
sword Peter in the wolf Peter Lee no
sword well actually mr. Aslan this is a
Disney film so there's not really
anything to clean off of it so before
the ice queen even knew what was
happening this small band of heroes
wiped down her entire camp
grabbed Edmund and it still had time to
tie up grumpy man hey we're gonna now
faster than Chinese food
Tony's not gonna be one of tasted okay
but weird is Nanyan toast come from
where does the flower come from why is
the bread so evenly cut do you toast it
on a campfire
it's not like Aslan can buy the bread
down at the local food line the older
sibling takes one turn practicing
archery and because it was Santa that
gave her the skier she ends up being
awesome at
and doesn't even need the practice my
name is Philip if the sequel to this
film had been about the life and times
of Philip the horsey they'd still be
making Narnia movies today so did they
do it everyone got up and reacted before
she even disturbed the curtain and
walked out apparently this roar is Magic
Jesus lion for bitch please the passion
of the lion this movie dwells and
lingers on the Jesus character's death
even more than the Bible does Jesus I
mean sorry
holy Christ I mean wow oh sure it sounds
all cool until the sensor when I say I
don't like it does an eye roll for my
wife
how does Susan know this I mean did she
take some sort of lion life science
class back at Finchley high she didn't
even take his pulse why is this even
allowed
why did the Ice Queen kill Aslan but
tell her entire army to peace out would
leave that lion body here for others to
mourn him or for him to come back to
life which he's obviously gonna do see
that's third time Susie smartypants
actually has a good point here they just
heard the White Witch say she's coming
to kill them all so maybe cut the bestir
morning short a bit and go give your
buddies a heads up chase treemail you
still my princes I bring grave news on
your sisters literally that's an army
out there it's ready to follow you I
can't cuz I believed you could sodalite
you were literally betraying him up
until a few minutes ago
the reasons I hope are well established
at this point I believe this giant eagle
can just go itself right in the ear
thank God they escaped the dangers of
World War two I'm sure these three are
supposed to be giants but am I alone and
thinking this looks more like three
regular blokes in a bad case of honey i
shrunk the mythical horde this Battle of
Helm's shallow will contain lots of
clanking metal and not a single drop of
blood at least four straight minutes of
battle I've seen done better by more
than one film or franchise the point is
that this film's biggest sin is
repetitive planus I mean who is actually
surprised by this way too much time
spent with Aslan explaining the table
the markings and does anyone else
remember there's a battle going on
generic we don't have done a better
battle footage once I a slant is alive
this movie becomes predictable as hell
good to see what condescend some help
sure it looks like the sword goes
through the arm here but in the
follow-up shots the sword clearly missed
his arm completely for pete's sake
literally it is finished and by finished
I mean still 20 minutes left in this
movie two more movie sequels and four
other books that still haven't been made
into movies but you know semantics I
give you Queen Lucy skip not only did
this joke conclusion from earlier seem
out of place and takes way too long to
pay off there was no way the charcoal
would have stayed on that line in this
long that King Albus Severus Potter you
were named after two headmasters of
Hogwarts and as such there are a few
rules we need to follow
there will be no shouting or running you
were to shoot the juice of the fire
flower I'm gonna start beating the view
the next five seconds
Lucy Lucy you got some splaining FIFA
thank you I just had it stuffed you
can't expect to wield supreme executive
power just cuz some watery tart through
a sword at you don't waste my time with
flattery this is gonna be a total
cluster cuz